turn it up good meet Brianna a 16 year
old high school senior who spent the
last seven weeks at Twitter she's not an
employee but one of the 20 students
accepted into girls who quote a program
that gives iSchool girls the opportunity
to get hands-on computer science
experience inside some of the biggest
companies in technology I didn't know
that what companies were like people
would tell me that like engineers
they're basically in cubicles all the
time and always on a screen but I see
like it's a lot more than that girls who
code represents what many hope to be
part of the solution to a long-standing
problem in Silicon Valley what's your
goal for girls who code
our goal is gender equity in STEM fields
generally and then computer science in
particular women account for 47 percent
of the u.s. workforce but just 30
percent of staff at Google Facebook and
Twitter and at Twitter women account for
only 10 percent of the technical staff
we're not too happy with those numbers I
think we would like to improve them then
that's entirely our goal twitter is one
of 16 companies that's opened its doors
to girls who code to help make this
change happen when I started doing
everything and girls who code I realized
that computer science is what I wanted
to do Twitter engineer no dirac Asahi
Nova is a girls who code mentor and
volunteer as a young girl one of the
reasons you don't get into computer
science is because you don't have any
idea of what kind of career it can lead
to cosine Nova learn to code at 14 then
skipped high school to study CS in
college and knows all too well what it's
like to be the only woman in the room
you would come into this class you've
never programmed before but there's some
guys in the class who have been
programming since they were nine girls
who cold wants to make coding a lot less
intimidating a lot more inspiring
talented women engineers like kusa anova
are in high demand for the hottest jobs
I interviewed at several places thank
God
six but it was good I prepared I worked
hard as this summer's program comes to a
close it's now up to these girls to
engineer their next move